the first time I spoke to my mum about
how I actually fully felt around my
dad's suicide was 13 years after it
happened exactly that's so much [ __ ]
time it's a long long way over a decade
exactly crazy it's a long while so I I'm
not belittling how tough that is
and we all have our own pressures that
make that either easier or more
difficult as well but I think it's about
okay well first of all understanding you
don't have to offload every single
detail of the blueprint of your
psychological makeup how can you make
that conversation as easy and as as
feasible as possible for you I think the
first is understanding okay what what
are you comfortable saying I don't have
to sit here and talk like Daniel's just
done for the first 20 minutes half an
hour of that podcast about every
interest intricacy in detail can I just
say two words I'm struggling that was
like the most that I could handle
right in that moment it was like this is
a lot two words is all I've got the next
day I said a full sentence my mum drove
up I said that I've been struggling with
depression anxiety suicidal ideation
I've got a bit of a problem with drugs
instead of full sentence
then I went to my therapist appointment
um and had the psycho psychiatric
appointment
um so the consultation before he
directed me to this the psychotherapist
he would ask me questions and again I
would talk to him a little bit more
about my history and then six months
later of working that muscle of
conversation I was able to sit down and
offload more
of the heavy stuff so it's about
understanding it's a process the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by VIN cherry and the
award-winning Source breaker